[Applaudissements]
je partie de chasse
c'est parti parti
[Applaudissements]
ah oui en effet il va les changer pour
la photocopieuse et bien sûr la
chronique cabinet ça y est lui il a fait
tous ces passages les dés sont jetés
pour camille combal très attention
maintenant le style partie de chasse
avec mathieu d'ormuz avez aimé ça j'ai
bien aimé et j'ai bien aimé oui oui bon
je n'ai pas trop apprécié l'expression
au visage mais j'ai bien aimé mon chaton
vent les prochains défilés allez c'est
parti partie de chasse par mathieu de
lambeaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il a nommés aux béquilles à ça
alors franchement magnifique oui oui en
effet c'est pourquoi à mon écoute
vraiment tu fais bien chez moi je pense
qu'elle en terme de non mais c'est vrai
tu vois ça y est il est bien sage il est
bien lui il fait bien sa chatte
redondant dans sa façon qu il s altérer
ds wii fait bienvenu bien ça vous allez
me dire tous les deux ici vous allez
vous mettre la zone d'agadez combal je
me maquille indienne camille combal
on va voir
sur twitter le sondage
attention on va avoir le sondage sur
twitter qui a fait le plus